this draw is breaking the chess internet
right now at the rapid and Blitz World
Championships Yan napesi and denil duab
decided to have some fun as they both
pranced their knights around the board
to open their game after 12 moves of
this back and forth the two mutually
agreed on a draw though it's fairly
common for players to arrive at a draw
early in a game it's not something that
is allowed to be pre-arranged per Fay's
rules the players shall take no action
that will bring the game of chess into
disrepute and based on the atypical
moves played the AR determined the draw
to be pre-arranged thus penalizing both
players by reducing the points they
scored rather than receiving the usual
half a point they each scored Zero The
Players however felt that there was no
issue with this given the circumstances
and 1 and a/ half hour time delay at the
event and have since taken actions by
appealing the decision the appeal was
ultimately denied by fiday and duab
finished the tournament in second place
just half a point behind the winner
Magnus Carlson tell us about your most
unusual draw below